the atlanta falcons made a roster move
today as they start into their
bye week tak mckinley
well he wanted out
he got out
and for mckinley
it's not really much of a punishment i
think the punishment is making him stay
on the team waving him today
is what he wanted the only problem is
he's got a path through waivers and he
could end up with a team he doesn't want
to play for but i think the only team he
didn't want to play for is the falcons
so he'll take his chances he'll roll the
dice and anywhere for the rest of the
season is better than where he was he'll
be a free agent after the season ends
unless someone would claim him he all of
a sudden goes off with 20 sacks over the
next half of the season and they decide
to franchise tag him so mckinley getting
what he wanted getting out of atlanta
and last week he had to take to twitter
to criticize the team he was fined for
the gesture but at the end of the day he
wanted out shireen he got out
he got out and i would be surprised if
anybody picks him up off waivers i think
he'll he'll be become a free agent and i
think he'll have a huge market you look
at teams competitive teams like the
titans and the seahawks and they need
pass rushers why wouldn't you roll the
dice on him for a low risk deal lots of
incentives in there and i know he's been
injured injured this season he's played
a total of 81 snaps missed the last two
games because of entry he's only played
four games this entire year and just
wasn't good for the falcons after they
made him a first round draft pick but he
has a chance if he can get healthy to go
somewhere and make a difference for the
rest of the year and and maybe he gets a
big contract in the off season if he can
get it done somewhere else
i am looking at the first round draft
picks from
2017. i believe that was his year am i
right am i right
you are correct mckinley he was the 26th
overall pick
his contract
is not fully guaranteed for the balance
of this season but the salary is only
1.858 million
i think that if you're gonna roll the
dice on the guy claim his contract
at a balance
yeah at a balance of about 900 000 for
the next eight weeks
take it because it's not guaranteed he
has 655 000 in skill injury and cap
guarantees for this year
and you know when it's partially
guaranteed i don't know how that plays
out is it
is it partial each week do you work at
all i should know this i've been doing
this for 20 years but even then that's
not much because
uh you pick him up you cut him you can
walk away from it with minimal risk if
you see something there maybe he was a
guy you really liked when he was coming
out of ucla maybe jim mora jr and i know
it's not technically junior jim moore
the elder will vouch for attack mckenna
i remember having him on pft live and he
went on and on about tak mckinley back
in 2017. so
i just think it's worth your due
diligence
because
pass rushers are always in demand and
there are plenty of teams that could use
the help and maybe there's just some
buttons that need to be pressed on tak
mckinley to get the most out of him but
you've got some teams out there that i
think could justify the risk and it may
just be that change of scenery shireen
is everything this guy needs
absolutely mike and you look back on
that draft you know i wrote on friday
that the cowboys had regret over two
picks after tat mckinley who they really
liked they selected taco charlton well
you know who both of those teams passed
up right tj what and if falcons could
have had tj watt i'm sure they're having
the same regret that the cowboys did
they picked the wrong pass rusher when
you look at what tj watt
has done and now as a candidate this
year for diva the player of the year i
think they who they would have much
preferred to have had tj watt but it
didn't work out for them but a lot of
teams like this guy coming out of
college obviously as a first round pick
for a reason he's going to get a chance
somewhere else now what do you do with
that second chance do you go make the
most of it and prove that you really are
a good pass rusher or you continue to do
what you did at atlanta which wasn't
very much in the course of 49 games he
had 17 and a half sacks
and let me just say this i don't want to
spend a whole lot of time on it but i am
reminded of this from time to time there
are many things to like about the draft
one thing that i loathe about the nfl
draft is that the coverage consists of a
non-stop parade of praise of every
first-round pick
every year
every guy all the upside all the
positive the media is complicit in this
manufacturing of hope arising from the
notion that every one of these guys
plucked off the board is going to be
great and it's almost part of the
contract that you sign to be part of the
draft coverage that you're going to
praise and praise and praise these guys
without ever acknowledging that you know
what those first round picks half of
them are going to not earn their money
half of them are not going to be any
good but no one wants to hear that this
whole thing has been built up into this
hype machine shireen where
you ignore the fact that it is a
crapshoot you ignore the fact that
you're rolling the dice you ignore the
fact that that taco charlton or tak
mckinley could have been tj watt forget
about that for a couple of reasons first
of all
we are collectively trying to sell hope
and nobody tunes in to see something
other than hope but also
if we acknowledge that half these guys
are going to be busts
the fans will say well which ones
and the draft experts even the most
seasoned and skilled will say well we
don't know to which the fans will
respond but why the hell are we listen
listening to you then so that just that
just bugs me that there's zero
transparency there's zero self-awareness
by espn nfl network any of the so-called
draft experts to say you know what at
the end of the day we don't know what
the hell we're doing and neither do the
teams
they don't mike and that's what's so
funny about it it's the same with free
agency too frankly i mean these players
change teams and we say oh they're going
to be great because they picked up so
and so so and so so and so and i
remember a few years ago remember when
the eagles had that huge off-season they
signed multiple
huge names in free agency and and vince
young tabbed them the dream team we've
got the dream team now in philadelphia
that didn't work out so well for the
eagles either so you're absolutely right
some moves you make are going to work
some moves you make aren't going to work
some draft picks are going to be good
some are not going to be good the teams
that that get above 50 percent usually
are the teams that are consistently good
you look at what the steelers do year
after year in the draft you look at
other teams like that that's why they're
successful mike they have a higher
success rate picking those guys than
than maybe other teams do
and here's the thing about free agents
guys who become free agents become free
agents for a reason the team has had
them in the building for four years
they know the guy inside and out and you
know what they're letting them walk away
that usually should tell you
all you need to know but still it's part
of the machinery it's part of the
selling of hope and yeah we're part of
it but at least we're willing to stand
up and say hey folks this is hardly the
the cure that your bad team is looking
for this offseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports